نحن الان نقف في منطقه بهلول هذه المنطقه
التي انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال صباح
اليوم بعد ان تمركزت لايام طويله في هذه
المنطقه حل الدمار الكبير وقوات الاحتلال
نسفت مجموعه من الابراج والكثير من
المباني قوات الاحتلال تعمدت على نسف
الكثير من المباني وتدمير الكثير من
البنايات في هذا في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه
الى تدمير البنيه التحتيه في هذه المنطقه
من تجريف شوارع
وتجريف مناطق الصرف الصحي وتجريف خطوط
المياه هذه المنطقه الان باتت للاسف مدمره
بشكل كبير جدا والدمار حل في هذا المكان
وكان زلزال ضرب الكثير من البنايات
والمنازل هي شارعي منطقتي وهي شوكان
والعماره كله راح نحن الان قرب مفترق
الكرامه هذه المنطقه هي مفترق الكرامه في
حين اننا نقف على انقاض اكبر مصلحه او
اكبر اكبر منشاه صناعيه او من اكبر
المنشات الصناعيه في مدينه غزه هذا مربع
ابراج الكرامه الذي تحدثنا عنه كثيرا تعرض
لاحمه ناريه وضرب في سبور وكثير من
الاجراءات التي حاول الاحتلال قبل ان
يدخلها اجراءات لمحاوله اخلاء هذه المنطقه
كل الابراج هذه من 294 لو فيها مشكله
وفيها ارهابيين وفيها غيره وغيره ليش ما
نزلت من 94 من 94 بنات نحن الان نقف فوق
انقاض ابراج المخابرات هذه الابراج او
البنيات السكنيه الكثيفه جدا اصبحت مدمره
بشكل كبير جدا الكثير منها سوي بالارض
وباقي هذه البنيات السكنيه وباقي هذه
الابراج اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن ايش بدك
اقول اكثر من اللي موجود اكثر من الدمار
اللي ننا فيه واكثر من العيشه اللي نن
عايشينها مجاعه وخبز فيشي وطحين فيشي وميه
فشي وكهرباء فيشي وحياه صغار صغار زي هذول
بنحرم من مدرستهم بيطلع ل منحاس والومنيوم
عشان يعيشوا ايش بدنا نقول اكثر من هيك
نحن الان نقف مقابل مستشفى حمد هذا
المستشفى الذي الي انشئ برعايه قطريه
لانشاء الاطراف الصناعيه نشاهد عن قرب
الدمار الذي حل في هذا المستشفى سواء
داخله او حتى في البنايه من
الخارج نحن الان نقف اقصى شمال غرب مدينه
غزه هذه المنطقه التي دمرت بشكل كامل سواء
منطقه المخابرات المقوسي بهلول للامن
العام الكرم كل هذه المناطق مدمره عشرات
البنايات السكنيه مسويه في الارض بالاضافه
الى عشرات الابراج الاخرى التي دم احياء
سكنيه مدمره واصبحت مكانا لا يصلح للسكن
اسماعيل الغول الجزيره مدينه غزه